kommt so ein bisschen noch mehr zu mir
sagen hey den kanal deine regeln wie bei
uns studiert dann stehe ich hilfe bat
verdienst dass konstruktive schwein das
ist ein bisschen wie die beauty youtuber
doch das funktioniert das allerdings
wieder einmal fand und bekam zu einer
neuen folge wie schmeckt und heute bin
ich nicht alleine da sondern mit der
großartigen eder
natürlich wäre das okay wir machen nicht
noch mal ja wir sind sie rechtlich wir
sind so spontan und youtube
und keiner sagt hallo du bist gerade bei
meinem erfolgreichsten forma also bist
du stolz darauf in meinem
erfolgreichsten formate sein ich bin ein
sehr großer fan von meinem format und
zweitens brauchen wir beides ein großer
fan wissen ist jeder zu mir gekauft
freut wenn er soll wir müssen unbedingt
die turtles pizza probieren machen
verschiedene ganz viel pizza turtles sag
mal was ist denn dieses teenage mutant
teenage mutant ninja turtles nochmal ein
teenager war das sind deine
lieblingsserie ja als kind ja auch
selber eine schildkröte ich hätte meine
gegründet ja ich wollte als kind auch
noch new york und an diese gullydeckel
wieder ernsthaft das war ich habe ziele
im leben
das thema was ist das denn für eine
serie geht es um schildkröten wie sehr
der handel der von vier schildkröten was
erstmal ziemlich lane klingt das klingt
auch noch frank lenz kennt so franklin
es auch eine schildkröte ist so eine
kinderserie da geht franken wenn man mit
seinen freunden zur schule und so auf
jeden fall ist es eine ganz andere
schildkröte ist ein anderes schicke das
sind super ninja ninja genau sie haben
auch so ein ninja boss also der ebenso
wie heißen dass ich bin da dieser rat es
nicht ist so ein weißer weißes frettchen
was so ihr mentors welcher super von
bart de du das interpretieren das war
der mentor der chef ich habe mich als
kind auch nie gefragt was mit ihm nicht
in ordnung ist warum dann ist er ganz
einfach wir wollen wir anfragen ok
teenage mutant ninja turtles spielt in
1984 kam die erste folge raus damals hat
man in amerika in new york pizza gerne
gegessen wir heute und wir haben einen
klassischen amerikanischen pizzateig
rausgesucht eine klassische new yorker
pizza soße und wer das nicht weiß die
teenage mutant ninja turtles haben mich
normale pizza gegessen
wir haben die immer belegt als auch die
ganz großes kino und das waren leute
ausprobieren einmal die deine popcorn
abholen pc sich historiker special treat
jetzt haben wir das sportangebot kann
das darf ich abbruch übernehmen weil
immer wenn er etwas richtig lecker
schmeckt dann ist dieses abbruch gefühlt
ja klar ich habe mein ganzes leben
abbach und den schulabbruch und für tag
brauchen wir drei mal eine halbe packung
schiefe zwei esslöffel olivenöl dann
zwei esslöffel world und ein teelöffel
salz das so ich hab einfach so 125
milliliter lauwarmes wasser
wir füllen 125 milliliter warmes wasser
in einen messbecher und brauchen jetzt
ein heiland packung trockenhefe flüssig
war frisch leser eine halbe packung
frischlinge brauchen wir jetzt auch
keine avastin super ich habe in meiner
hand rauchen brad pitt man sich
erleichtert
lifehacker selbst gesagt ich kann das
perfekt und ich meine das kritisch
was ist los mit mir so sie bekommt jetzt
da rein und muss sich auflösen denn was
passiert mit der hilfe ev was damit
passiert am ende geht doch sie weil ich
die lust auf dieses werk denn ich habe
letztens gelernt habe ist kein bakterien
das ist ein ps hefe ist kein bakterien
das ist ein bild
hierfür ist ein ps und hat richtig lust
auf zucker männer haben war das bild so
gerne haben schon so bin ich auch ein
paar jetzt kommt zwei esslöffel olivenöl
in eine andere schüsseln 2
aber jede richtung wieso keine irgendwie
ist schon ein bisschen fetisch oder wenn
robbie versteht es wie mit benzin gibt
menschen die verstehen das gar nichts
mit benzin alle tankstelle ja als kind
war es richtig so
jetzt kommen noch zwei esslöffeln
joghurt in dieser story man nicht
gespritzt das klingt so ein filmtitel
und vanessa kochen folge schon jetzt
richtig abgespritzt jetzt berühren jetzt
führt er damit den hochnebel wieso man
kommt kann es sei ich sag immer wieder
weil ich mir irgendwann mal eingeprägt
hat vanessa als humus leader sein
das ist ihr richtiger name und das kommt
auch mal tagte die mich dass ihr das ist
jetzt nur wieder ein telefon ist die
eltern nicht hinterfragt ob nun feiert
die hilfe mischung und die joghurt öl
mischung hochzeit im sommer ja wow ist
das weiße band gucken jetzt schon fast
aus wie pizza mit 300 gramm mehl und das
mega und jetzt unsere schlüssel passt im
moment ist es vielleicht die kamera
macht längst diesen schwierig papier hat
kann ich mir mit der hand kann ist mir
richtig anstrengen
das ist einfach sehr harte arbeit hat
sich nicht einbauen sollte man uns
verraten was denn der teig wird richtig
gut
drückt man mit dem finger drauf
fühlt sich gut an du sagst du auch nicht
so klingt auch wie so ein typisches okay
du bist nicht du jetzt hier gar nicht
rein aber ich muss das jetzt mal wie er
hat mir sein neues album 24 hours druck
mit mehr hab ich mal nicht und ich so
das sag ich immer der eine komplette
druck auf diese art und weise wie er das
wie das singen was ich mich mal nicht
eins zu eins so ausgesprochen und ist
warum kommt mir das so bekannt vor und
nicht so hauke du hast du mich
verarschen so gehört es wahrscheinlich
von einem liebeslied folgen hab mich mal
ne super liebeslied so und ich zeige ich
dir jetzt die richtigen italien treten
nämlich nicht nur ihren teig sondern
macht euch gesagt ich würde die streiche
yamaha
deswegen müssen jetzt nicht in frage und
amerikaner aggressive schliffen drauf
entweder kann man jetzt den teil über
nacht auf gehen lassen oder wir machen
es so wie wir es gleich tun werden und
packen so bei ungefähr 40 grad in den
ofen dass der hat mir so ein bisschen
ein bisschen warm wird und dann geht
also ganz schnell auch verzichten und
datei ist fertig einfach voran
das war ja nur 50 grad ist ein profi
dass man hinten sorgen
ja wer ist richtig lustig wie christa
aufgegangen ist vermutlich habe ja nun
morgen geschneit dass es gesehen ja ich
war schockiert da komplett überfordert
weiß warum so wenn man es weiß damals
die richtige berlinerin
wieso berliner hassen winter jetzt knie
dass du einmal so den teig zu einer
schönen kugel ja schließlich befolgen
müssten wir das gebot machen oder ist
das ja mitteilte habe ich ob ich das
machen muss aber okay und dann so und
jetzt haben wir jetzt eine schöne google
so darf ich jetzt auch ja ja das ist der
perfekte die decke man sollte keine luft
kein licht ohne dienstag ist bradley
das ist ein perfekter pizzateig jetzt
hat gar nicht mehr auf sich komisch an
gehören okay wir sind fertig und jetzt
und jetzt müssen die leute auf deinen
kanal gehen ach so geht auf einer skala
genau da geht es nämlich weiter und es
wird richtig gelebt jetzt fängt
eigentlich alles an ja jetzt wird darauf
klicken
ich denke hier ist viel platz dass